Farming, as we now
associate the word,
has been around for about
7,000 to 10,000 years.
And when we think of
farming, we imagine a farmer
planting seeds, and later
harvesting the crops.
Or maybe having cattle that
they can allow to graze,
and then using that cattle for
either meat, or milk, or wool.
But there's actually a
different type of farming
that predates this association
with I guess what we could call
the traditional form of farming.
And it predates it by several
tens of thousands of years.
And we believe that it started
with the original inhabitants
of Australia.
And what they did is-- and this
is why we call it farming--
and because if you
think about farming
in the most general sense, it's
really humans using technology
to manipulate their
environment so it
becomes more
suitable for humans.
So it becomes more
suitable for things
that humans might want to eat,
or get milk from, or whatever.
And this type of farming is
called firestick farming.
And I think you can already
imagine what it might involve.
It involves using fire, which
is really a form of technology--
or it can be a form of
technology-- using fire
to make the environment more
suitable for human activity.
And so what the original
Australians did--
the indigenous
Australians, or sometimes
referred to as the
Aboriginal Australians.
And if you're wondering where
the word Aboriginal comes from,
you might recognize
some parts of it.
Original-- you know
what that means.
The first things.
The things that were
there from the beginning.
And then you have ab,
which is Latin for from.
So this is literally
from the beginning.
So when you say
Aboriginal Australians,
you're really saying
the Australians
that were there
from the beginning.
And so what they would do is, is
that we believe if you go back
50,000 or 60,000 years
before the first Aboriginal
Australians settled Australia,
Australia had much more forest.
It still has forest.
This is a modern
picture, obviously,
of an Australian forest.
But what they did is that
they set up controlled burns.
And what these
controlled burns did
is that they cleared
away a lot of the forest.
They cleared away a lot of
the brush that's over here,
and it made it
much more suitable
for grassland to develop.
And the reason why they
liked grassland-- so let's
make a little cycle
here of what they did.
So they have controlled burns.
Controlled fires.
Those controlled fires
helped promote grassland.
And then once you
have grassland,
that made the
environment more suitable
for animals that the
original human settlers
could essentially live off of.
That they could hunt, that
they could potentially
eat their meat.
And so, for example,
things like kangaroos.
And these supported
the human population,
which obviously, would then
do the controlled burns.
And you see here-- so we
could have started off
with something like this.
Someone provides
a controlled burn.
And they were actually
pretty scientific
about how they did it.
They wouldn't just go at the
end of summer, when everything
was hot, and ready
to just blow up,
and then start a fire that
they couldn't control.
They would often do
these in seasons knowing
that it had a certain level
of moisture in the air,
it wasn't too hot.
And to a large degree, by
doing these controlled burns,
not only did it provide an
environment-- kind of do
this firestick
farming-- not only did
it provide an environment
that was suitable for things
like kangaroos, some type of
things that humans could eat--
but it also prevented
major fires.
And you still see forest rangers
doing this type of thing.
And there's some
reason to believe
that what the original
Australians did, on some level,
was more nuanced and
more fine-tuned than even
what we do, in a modern
sense, in controlled burns.
So these controlled fires also
prevented major uncontrollable
fires.
Because what happens
is if you don't
have these controlled
fires, then you
have brush building up,
year after year after year.
You have stuff building up.
And then, when the
fires do occur,
the uncontrolled fires are
less likely to be started
during the winter,
when the air is cool
or when there might
be some moisture.
They're more likely to
occur in the dry season.
So you have all
this stuff build up.
And then when the
fire does happen,
it happens in the driest season.
And then what happens with
all of the stuff built up
in the dry season, it just
becomes uncontrollable.
One of the byproducts--
or actually there
are several byproducts of this
firestick farming-- we believe,
is a lot of the
grassland in Australia
now might have been
more forested before.
And even when the
first European settlers
came in the late 1700s,
they were kind of surprised
when they went into what is now
Sydney Harbor and they said,
wow, look at all
the grassland here.
It almost looks like park space.
And then they would let
their sheep graze there.
And they were
surprised-- because they
had driven out the
original inhabitants.
And then they were
surprised when forests just
started to grow up
in that grassland.
And it was because the original
Australians were actually
controlling that
forest growth to make
it more inhabitable for
things like kangaroos.
And then when the
English settlers came,
they started to have their
sheep graze in those grasslands.
And it also was responsible
for the disappearance,
we think, of many
major-- I guess,
for lack of a better
word-- megafauna.
So really large animals
that inhabited Australia,
for really millions of years,
until humans showed up.
And this is one of them.
It's just neat to look at them.
This is called
Diprotodon optatum.
Or, another way to think
of it, the giant wombat.
And there's fossils of the
giant wombat around 40,000,
50,000 years ago.
But they disappeared
with humans showing up.
And there's multiple
ways that you
can think about why
they disappeared.
They might have--
and this is probably
the case-- they might have been
more dependent on the forest
habitat.
Or this was a more
favorable habitat for them
than the grasslands.
Maybe because they ate
leaves that were high up.
Or another thing is, once
the forest habitat goes away,
they were actually also
easier to hunt down.
Or either way you
think about it,
they might have just
been hunted by humans.
But we do see that
with humans coming
to the Australian
continent, you start
to see the disappearance--
and this isn't the only one--
but there were several
major species of megafauna,
of super large animals, that
disappeared at that time
period.